venezuela lucha contra la inflación por
lo que a partir del 1 de octubre entrará
en vigor la reconversión del bolívar es
decir un cambio del sistema monetario
para simplificar transacciones por ello
van a retirar 6 ceros y la moneda se
llamará bolívar digital en france24 el
profesor luís crespo aseguró que se
trata de un cambio cosmético en primer
término es importante clara que el
anuncio de una nueva moneda no viene
acompañado de un plan económico no hay
ningún anuncio que este oriente sobre la
resolución de los problemas
macroeconómico el país se trata de la
tercera reconversión desde 2008 cuando
comenzó a circular el bolívar fuerte y
se quitaron tres ceros diez años después
surgió el bolívar soberano y se quitaron
otros cinco ceros la nueva reconversión
busca recuperar el bolívar en un momento
que los billetes habían desaparecido
mientras el dólar es la moneda que
circula esto se debe a que un millón de
bolívares sólo costaba 25 centavos de
dólar y los sistemas de pago no podían
soportar cifras tan altas venezuela ha
quitado 14 ceros en 13 años
parte de la ciudadanía teme las
consecuencias para un ya debilitado
poder adquisitivo que se consciente que
sólo que atraer es un aumento en los
precios seguramente 6 para los salarios
en el anuncio del gobierno venezolano
también ha insistido en el desarrollo de
la economía digital y su apuesta a la
modernización de los sistemas de pago ya
en 2017 el gobierno de nicolás maduro
había creado en petros una divisa
digital que tenía intención de blindar
la economía y derrocar la hegemonía del
dólar